camille combal alors on entend tout sur
lui celle en quête de baba et on vous
dira tout dans un instant que vous allez
me donner votre avis et garantissent que
je vous donnais une info concernant
camille regarde voilà déjà six ans que
camille combal nous régale tous les
soirs dans touche pas à mon poste avec
ces séquences tels que les enfants de
stars
ils en pensent quoi ton frère ou encore
l'inspecteur derrick
ecoute-moi bien des deux hubs on peut
allègrement avancé qu'il est devenu un
pilier
pourtant le jeune homme a pris la
décision de quitter l'émission du
pakistano tunisien cyril hanouna
pire encore le trublion du paf aurait
refusé toutes les propositions venant du
groupe canal + le saltimbanque voudrait
en effet volé de ses propos a vite
si l'intéressé connaît sa prochaine
destination il reste pour le moment muet
comme une carpe
alors camille combal va-t-il aller sur
france 2 remuer les boules de thierry
beccaro
at il raison de quitter le groupe pour
peut-être partir sur m6 et présentée
mariée au premier regard et surtout si
cyril et camille se séparent qui
s'occupera de leur enfant mokhtar toutes
ces questions auxquelles l'inspecteur
baba va tenter de répondre et je vous
donne l'info oui c'est vrai
camille combal ne sera plus dans le
groupe canal+ l'année prochaine on ne
sait pas encore où il va mais il ne sera
plus dans le groupe canal l'année
prochaine camille pouvez me poser après
quelques questions mais juste à dire
déjà première question que je vous pose
est ce que vous pensez qu'il a raison de
quitter le groupe canal+ pour dire voilà
ce que vous en pensez
christine moi je trouve qu'il a tort
parce que alors c'est un travers de
beaucoup de chroniqueurs en général
lorsqu'on et c'est arrivé un peu à tout
le monde on se sent bien dans une
émission et on espère autre chose avoir
sa propre émission
mais c'est très difficile parce que par
exemple dans cette émission moi j'ai
l'impression que c'était pmp qui porte
les chroniqueurs et pas l inverse
je pense qu'il faut d'abord passer la
marque de l'émission en plus passer la
marque du groupe
et ce n'est pas facile de s'adapter seul
ailleurs dans un autre groupe dans une
autre chaîne beaucoup ont essuyé les
plâtres et je peux vous citer capucine
enora malagré ceux qui sont partis et
c'est bien droite charles thibault qui a
trouvé un truc koala qui a fait ça bien
taré kireev bertrand chamerois que
bertrand charmera club georgie qui n'a
pas très bien marché on a eu aussi
capucine qui est parti faire son nos
théâtres ensuite un livre
et puis un bon ça n'a pas fort sur des
gens qui ont beaucoup de talent tout
simplement des gens qui ont beaucoup de
talent mais je veux dire que c'est pas
facile de quitter un concept et de et de
s'exporter ailleurs c'est assez
compliqué mais là il me valérie moi à
titre personnel ça me fait beaucoup de
peine que camille s'en aille parce que
c'est un compagnon de route depuis six
ans maintenant et je pense alors après
c'est mon chou
mon sentiment qu'ils auraient choyé ici
c'est à dire que s'il voulait grandir il
pouvait grandir mais la wii ou là où il
est il est né et on l'aurait accompagné
et je pense que la chaîne aurait été
encore plus aux petits oignons
qu'ailleurs où on va peut-être lui
demandez peut-être plus que ce qu'il ne
peut supporter recovery agathe
oui moi je pense également qu'il a tort
surtout que camille faisait partie de
ces de ses chroniqueurs à qui vous avez
déjà donné beaucoup de choses il avait
quand même sa quotidienne ils en pensent
quoi kamin que vous aviez créé pour lui
et c'est lui de ses choix personnels
parce qu'il avait la radio le matin plus
sacrés mais voilà qui a décidé d'arrêter
certaines choses mais c'est pas comme si
on lui avait rien proposé est comme si
on lui laissait pas les portes ouvertes
donc moi je comprends pas son choix le
match ce qui me choque moi c'est que si
on lui proposait quelque chose qui
partait pour un projet pourquoi pas mais
il a l'air de dire qu'il ne sait pas ce
qu'il va faire donc sévère qui parle
pour rien leur appétit par juste parce
qu'en fait il y en a marre d'être ici et
comment est ce qu'il peut en avoir marre
d'être ici alors que pardon ça a été le
plus gâté drink la chaîne il a eu des
prime même des prades juste sur son nom
il est une quotidienne
il est ici tous les soirs dans
l'émission la chaîne je le sais je
verrai à dire mais lui a fait des
propositions encore pour l'année
prochaine avec de jolies choses mais
dans la dombes et neemia voilà il ya un
moment où on peut pas lui proposer plus
que tout ce qu'on lui offre
et malgré tout ça ne suffit pas donc je
pense qu'il va peut-être apprendre que
souvent mal et l'herbe n'est pas plus
verte qu'ailleurs il va le regretter je
pense alors julien moi si vous perdez
j'ai pas être d'accord avec vous avez
déjà je suis pas certain qu'on lui
propose plus ailleurs et qu il parte
pour plus je pense qu'à un moment donné
moi j'ai vécu c'est avec gérard louvin
qui m'a fait grandir j'ai démarré à la
terrasse je suis resté huit ans à un
moment donné on a envie de couper le
cordon avec le père et on ait envie de
se dire c'est moi le no mercy compris
c'est vous le permet bien sûr et on a
envie de se dire bien moi aussi en fait
là bas ils vous rendent non mais
franchement je sais que ça va paraître
qq ce que je dis mais il vous rend
hommage en disant c'est par admiration
j'ai envie moi même d'avoir une carrière
comme lui je l'attend et prend un risque
prime à ses rangs dire mais à son âge si
lui ne prend pas de risque avec le
talent qu'il a qui va prendre un risque
gilles je suis absolument pas d'accord
avec julien courbet vous fait d'une
erreur vérité vous au raku dessus
maman tu n'as beaucoup des thrillers
julien courbet vous tombé très bas
tiens croyable doit comprendre à l'essai
une erreur magistrale c'est un gâchis
pour le groupe car et c'est là où ça se
passe j'ai l'impression d'un caprice ou
d'un malentendu
j'aimerais qu'il se ressaisit je
comprends pas cette décision j'ai envie
de lui dire les yeux dans les yeux
mon gars tu fais n'importe quoi voilà
l'état sous peine parce que vous l'avez
fait grandir ce que ce que dit julien
besson est en partie vrai mais surtout
il avait de la radio salle fatigué donc
je me dis maintenant qu'il n'ya plus la
radio il peut se concentrer l'année
prochaine il pourrait se concentrer
effectivement sur des projets à lescar
et son voisin qui était beaucoup moins
en tout cas ça m'attriste beaucoup et je
sens qu'ils auraient dû faire une amende
plus ici voilà neuf ans arrivé dans le
panier de la mariée
oui mais plus parce que ça on n'a pas
d'info août est un jour voilà
franchement tamara wittes à me cacher la
vérité voilà on l'a d'or le groupe
l'adorent moi je vous dire après ce que
j'en pense également est camille il sait
à peu près voilà ce qu'est ce qu'ils
avaient envie de payer en dehors de vous
laver faire ce qu'ils voyaient en plein
fouet en dehors de mon groupe
concrètement jean michel joux touba moi
je trouve je trouve qu'il a tort mais
parce que moi je suis un peu j'aime bien
la sécurité schumi chassaing peut-être
la croix pour l'ombre ici ils étaient
ses lacets dans ma famille il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire à canal jeu
c'est une chaîne qui rend reconstruction
dont il y avait énormément de projets de
choses vous pouvez trouver sa place les
grèves sont très durs à la télévision
ces raretés greffe marche comme ça si
vous vouliez pas attendu que par des
amis là où il va donc je trouve ici ils
étaient bien elle propose des choses il
pouvait encore faire plein de choses
c'est dommage tu parles à l'oeil
extérieur de sophie mais qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous alors moi je vous
apprécie la france télévisions pendant
30 ans paraguay mais bon moi je sais pas
forcément un exemple je suis en partie
d'accord avec julien c'est vrai que je
comprends qu'il ait envie de tuer le
père c'est la hausse la grande thèse de
william leymergie quand il parlait jury
aux producteurs mais d'un autre côté il
ya une grande différence entre être un
très bon chroniqueur d'une émission et
être un animateur est forte et un
programme soi même et on a vu quand même
beaucoup d'exemples de chroniqueurs qui
rêvait de porter un programme et qu'ils
ont échoué
donc voilà je suis partagé c'est
compliqué c'est vrai qu'il a énormément
de talent et qu'il est il était
formidable est écouté j'avais des
formules hop voilà g appelé benjamin
boyer une info accès info ou intox
on leur a proposé des repêchages
dans mon coeur quiz oui mais non c'est
une fausse info le lymphome pour
l'instant on va pas parler de ce qui va
faire ou ce qui va pas faire on parle
beaucoup de danse avec les stars
je vous dis moi je vous dire ce qui
s'est passé voilà c'est camille il
discute avec canal+
ça c'est pas bien goupillé voilà pour
différentes choses voilà c'est ça c'est
un peu traîné mais voilà on a et camille
voilà il a décidé donc de voler de ses
propres ailes
moi je franchement il a fait passer six
ans avec moi on a fait des choses
vraiment son nom c'est on n'a jamais
autant rigolé on a fait des magnétos
vraiment j'en ai pleuré de rire et nous
a fait tous les jours une chronique je
vous dis dans le poste de surveillance
qui était pratiquement voilà tous les
soirs excellente
maintenant moi je suis un peu vous allez
prendre prendre pour un fou mais je suis
un petit peu de la vie de julien courbet
je pense qu'à un moment c'est vrai que
il faut aussi savoir voler de ses
propres ailes moi je pense qu'il a
beaucoup beaucoup de talent qu'il a
passé des moments fabuleux avec moi et
je pense qu'il a envie parce que dans le
groupe canal je pense que khamis et 10
dans le groupe canal je serai toujours
voilà quand même sous la compagnie cyril
et cyril aura toujours un oeil sur moi
je vous dis la vérité il s'est dit voilà
il va nous dire vrai pourquoi tu fais
pas ci pourquoi tu fais pas ça en plus
comme je suis un cs bonbons on peut
arrêter c'est comme les séjours de foot
à qui on dit il et fou d'aller à
manchester united il aura ya trop de
concurrence y est tout le temps sur le
banc à un moment donné le type il envie
de dire mais non je veux savoir quelle
est ma valeur
élève a vraiment là ça vaut exactement
il présida vraiment à savoir mais je
vais vous dire moi voilà moi je suis
très déçu qu'ils partent
voilà du groupe ce que j'aurais vraiment
préféré qu'il reste dans le groupe mais
je peux comprendre
voilà sa décision masques et je pense sa
décision à l'iss un pl est clair c'est
que il avait juste envie
il m'a dit je crois qu'on sera toujours
de vote avec camilla est vraiment on se
délie est juste il avait envie de vivre
un petit peu sa carrière sans moi voilà
et scénique dans le groupe canal voilà
ce serait plus compliqué oui une
question est ce que vous pouvez clairet
ma lanterne cyril parce que non mais
parce que il ya quand même des rumeurs
persistantes sur le départ de camille
vers le groupe tf1 vraie fausse mais il
me semble que ara aprikian qui
aujourd'hui à tf1 anciennement s'est
vite ne voulait pas de camillo des
droits alors sur le sueur sur la lune
avis c'est vrai que c'est moi qui ai
vraiment imposé camille je vous le dis
sur sur ces mythes sur d8 à l'époque
parce que j'y croyais à fond je l'avais
vue sur w9 chez lui j'ai eu un coup de
coeur pour ce garçon et c'est vrai car
appris qu'on voit là
mais après quand je vous dis la vérité
il vient tout souvent après la bataille
autant j'aime prend camille combal
autant râperie quand il est venu il a
pris touche pas à mon poste était sur
france 4
yann barthès ça cartonnait sur canal il
l'a pris burger quiz il a su qu'on le
prenait pas ici jeter dessus a appris
qu'un c'est un petit peu la voiture
balai du tour de france donc voilà donc
c'est vrai que vrai mais c'est la vérité
donc c'est vrai que voilà il prend un
petit peu tout je comprends pas c'est
très bien parce que ça lui réussit
j'espère que ça continuera
en tout cas il ya quelqu'un à qui je
n'en voudrai jamais et non je serai
toujours derrière lui c'est camille
combal je voulais me tairai sortir ne
dit pas ce que je vais peut-être
fourguer mon émission de barbecue sur
tf1 mais je vous dis camille qu'on lui
en voudrais je souhaite énorme succès
pour l'instant il va rester avec nous
jusqu'à la fin de la saison et j'espère
vraiment que tu fais le bon choix oui
est ce que vous pensez honnêtement que
camille combal serait ou sera un bon
animateur pour moi pour moi c'est
aujourd'hui un des garçons qu'elle plus
de talent voilà je vous lance un
programme seul après à prévoir après
chig été très fort sur les images tout
ça faudra pas mais en tout cas je
souhaite énormément mais vraiment
énormément de succès vraiment à kamnik
je vois là je les aime énormément
est ce que j aurais parlé se mêlent
cordon mais aussi dans les cei que tu
verras oh c'est peut-être un peu tôt
mais à la place du téléspectateur je
veux demander un
est ce que vous êtes francs cyril a
franchement premièrement deuxième mot
qui a trahi qui on a l'impression que ou
bien vous avez trahi
non c'est une question que je pose je me
mets à la paire médéa régulateur je leur
ai une question il ya par exemple le
monde j'aurais po lu qui reste voilà
camille je crois qu'il voulait rester au
début et puis il a dû à voilà il a eu
des propositions à droite à gauche
forcément et je pense qu'il a envie de
tenter sa chance comme il nous l'a dit
si et envie de tenter sa chance tout
seul sans moi on restera potes on s'en
rappellera tous les jours je vous le dis
on lui s'être a beaucoup de succès sur
tf1 ça sera plus compliqué non mais
franchement voilà mais je pense voilà je
gens plus franchement je pense que ça
sera plus vers tf1 tmc
c'est vrai que ce sont pas nos amis mais
bon qu'est ce que vous voulez il ya des
joueurs lèvent et à des joueurs qui
étaient au psg ou à l'om et qui ont
signé au psg
huawei et ça c'est donc à bien par
ailleurs il n'est pas allé les chéris
mais ça veut c'est en tout cas ce
vraiment je l'aimais et je l'aimerai
toujours et je pense qu'il va cartonner